>>> WELL, THIS WEEK, GOVERNOR
RON DeSANTIS EFFECTIVELY ASKED
THE STATE LEGISLATURE FOR HIS
VERY OWN ELECTION POLICE FORCE.
IT'S CALLED THE OFFICE OF
ELECTION CRIME AND SECURITY.
IT WOULD, QUOTE, INVESTIGATE,
DETECT, APPREHEND AND ARREST
ANYONE FOR AN ALLEGED VIOLATION
OF ELECTION LAWS.
ACTING ON TIPS FROM GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS OR ANY OTHER PERSON.
THE 52-MEMBER POLICE SQUAD WOULD
COST TAX PAYERS ALMOST $6
MILLION.
THE REAL PROBLEM WITH THE
PROPOSAL IS THERE IS NO EVIDENCE
OF WIDESPREAD VOTER FRAUD
ANYWHERE IN FLORIDA AND EVEN
LESS EVIDENCE THE PROBLEM
WARRANTS A SPECIAL POLICE FORCE.
FOR THE RECORD, OF THE MORE THAN
18 MILLION VOTES CAST IN FLORIDA
THROUGHOUT 2020, FLORIDA
OFFICIALS REFERRED JUST 75
COMPLAINTS TO LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
AT THAT RATE, IT IS ESSENTIALLY
A NONISSUE.
DON'T BELIEVE ME?
WELL, YOU CAN JUST ASK DeSANTIS
HIMSELF.
>> THE WAY FLORIDA DID IT, I
THINK, INSPIRES CONFIDENCE, I
THINK THAT'S HOW ELECTIONS
SHOULD BE RUN.
WE'RE NOW BEING LOOKED AT AS THE
STATE THAT DID IT RIGHT AND THE
STATE THAT THESE OTHER STATES
SHOULD EMULATE.
>> THAT WAS NOVEMBER 2020.
DOES THAT SOUND LIKE A GOVERNOR
SO CONCERNED ABOUT ELECTION
INTEGRITY THAT HE NEEDS A NEW
OFFICE TO COMBAT THE PROBLEM?
OPPONENTS SAY IT'S ABOUT MUCH
MORE THAN THAT.
>> FOR THE GOVERNOR TO DOUBLE
DOWN ON THESE EFFORTS NOW, WHEN
THERE WAS NO EVIDENCE OF VOTER
FRAUD OR ELECTION FRAUD DURING
THE 2020 ELECTION, SUGGESTS TO
ME THAT THIS ALSO IS POLITICALLY
MOTIVATED.
>> POLITICALLY MOTIVATED.
IT IS NO SECRET, DeSANTIS IS
WEIGHING A 2024 PRESIDENTIAL
RUN, BUT THIS BRINGS POLITICAL
PANDERING TO A WHOLE NEW LEVEL.
AND IN GEORGIA, FORMER GOP
SENATOR TURNED CANDIDATE FOR
GOVERNOR DAVID PURDUE IS
FOLLOWING SUIT.
PROMISING TO MAKE HIS OWN
ELECTION POLICE FORCE IF HE
WINS.
IT'S ONLY A MATTER OF TIME
BEFORE OTHER REPUBLICAN-LED
STATES JOIN IN, TOO, BUT LET'S
BE CLEAR.
PURDUE AND DeSANTIS CLAIM THIS
IS ABOUT PROTECTING ELECTION
INTEGRITY, BUT IT WOULD REALLY
DO IS ERODE WHAT LITTLE TRUST
THERE IS LEFT IN OUR DEMOCRACY.
AND JOINING ME NOW TO DISCUSS IS
PROFESSOR OF AFRICAN AMERICAN
STUDIES AT VANDERBILT
UNIVERSITY, MICHAEL ERIC DYSON.
HIS NEW BOOK IS CALLED
"ENTERTAINING RACE."
YOU'VE STUDIED VOTER SUPPRESSION
FOR YEARS.
GIVE US YOUR REACTION TO THIS
PUSH FOR ELECTION POLICE FORCES.
>> AS YOU STATED IT, MS. BROWN,
THIS WOULD DISCOURAGE LEGITIMATE
VOTERS FROM COMING TO THE POLLS,
BLACK VOTERS, POOR VOTERS, POOR
WHITE VOTERS, ELDERLY VOTERS,
ARE ALREADY SUBJECT TO ARBITRARY
FORMS OF, YOU KNOW, KIND OF
LOCKDOWN, WHEN IT COMES TO
VOTING.
BEING MISLED BY ROBO-CALLS.
HAVING I.D. LAWS STRINGENTLY
APPLIED.
YOU CAN HAVE AN I.D. FOR A GUN
AND YOU CAN REGISTER OR IT BE
ACCEPTED TO VOTE, BUT NOT IF YOU
HAVE ONE FOR SNAP OR ONE FOR A
STUDENT I.D.
SO, WE KNOW THAT THE TARGETING
OF COMMUNITIES OF COLOR, OF POOR
COMMUNITIES, OF YOUNGER
POPULATIONS, IS WHAT THE
ULTIMATE GOAL HERE IS, AND IF
THE GOVERNOR SAID THAT FLORIDA
WAS THE EXEMPLARY STATE, THE
PARADIGM OF REASONABLE VOTING
AND LEGITIMATE VOTING, WHY NOW
ALL OF A SUDDEN, WITHOUT AN
OUTBREAK OF VOTER FRAUD HERE?
AS YOU'VE SAID, 75 CASES
REFERRED TO THE POLICE OUT OF 18
MILLION VOTES?
THAT'S AN EXTRAORDINARY RECORD
AND ONE TO BE COMMENDED.
AND SO, WHAT WE KNOW HERE IS
THAT VOTER SUPPRESSION IS AFOOT
THAT THE REPUBLICANS HAVE
INTRODUCED LAWS IN 48 STATE
LEGISLATURES AND SOME 400 BILLS,
TO, IN ONE WAY OR ANOTHER,
SUPPRESS THE VOTE OF PEOPLE OF
COLOR, OF POOR PEOPLE, OF
ELDERLY PEOPLE, AND IT WREAKS OF
FASCIST RETALIATION AGAINST THE
FACT THAT THESE PEOPLE HAVE
TURNED OUT IN RECORD NUMBERS TO
VOTE.
WHY DON'T THE REPUBLICANS WANT
MORE VOTES, NOT LESS?
MORE PEOPLE INVOLVED, NOT LESS?
IF YOU ARE INVESTED IN MAKING
AMERICA THE BEST THAT IT CAN BE,
THEN WE WANT EVERY VOTE TO
COUNT.
>> DO YOU SEE SIMILARITIES
BETWEEN THIS AND SOME OF THE
SUPPRESSION TACTICS USED AGAINST
AFRICAN AMERICANS DURING JIM
CROW?
>> THERE IS NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
THINK ABOUT POLICEMEN ON HORSES,
RIDING ROUGH SHOD OVER
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS.
THINK ABOUT POLICE DOGS RIPPING
AT THE FLESH OF BLACK PEOPLE.
THINK ABOUT JELLY BEAN TESTS,
THINK ABOUT POLL TESTS, THINK
ABOUT LITERACY TESTS.
ALL OF THESE WERE DEPLOYED TO
TRY TO PREVENT BLACK PEOPLE FROM
EXERCISING THEIR VOTE AND
LEVERAGE AT THE POLLS.
AND SO, I -- THERE'S A STRIKING
SIMILARITY AND A DANGEROUS ONE,
BETWEEN WHAT WENT ON IN THE '50s
AND '60s IN THIS COUNTRY AND
WHAT'S GOING ON TODAY IN THE
NAME OF EXPANDED DEMOCRACY AND
ATTACKS AGAINST VOTER FRAUD.
>> IT IS TRUE, THOUGH, THAT
THERE IS A PROBLEM WITH TRUST IN
THE SYSTEM AMONG REPUBLICANS.
JUST 13% SAY THEY ARE VERY
CONFIDENT IN OUR ELECTION SYSTEM
AND THE MAJORITY SAY THEY
BELIEVE TRUMP WON THE ELECTION.
DeSANTIS SAYS, THIS IS ABOUT
INCREASING THEIR CONFIDENCE IN
THE SYSTEM.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THAT
ARGUMENT?
>> YEAH, THAT'S NOT TRUE.
FIRST OF ALL, IT IS A SHAME AND
ATROCIOUS THAT 13% OF
REPUBLICANS BELIEVE THAT THE
ELECTION WAS STOLEN.
THIS IS THE TRUMPETING OF A
TRUMP WHO REFUSES TO ACCEPT THE
FACT THAT HE LOST FAIR AND
SQUARE.
SO, THE BIG LIE HAS BEEN
AMPLIFIED IN STATES EVEN THAT
MR. TRUMP WENT AFTER, WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT ARIZONA OR GEORGIA
OR EVEN IN PENNSYLVANIA.
THESE REPUBLICAN STRONGHOLDS, AT
LEAST IN TERMS OF THE OFFICIALS
THERE, SAID NO, WE ARE NOT THE
ONES WHO ENGAGED IN SUPPRESSION
AND THAT THE VOTE COULDN'T BE
TRUSTED.
BUT HERE WE FIND OUT, AS SOON AS
THE VOTES HAVE BEEN CERTIFIED
AND DEMOCRACY TOOK PLACE IN A
REASONABLE FASHION, THEY TURN
AROUND TO INTRODUCE LAWS THAT
WILL -- THAT WILL POWERFULLY
SUPPRESS THE VOTE OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
AND WE KNOW, FOR INSTANCE, AMONG
MANY REPUBLICANS, THEY HAVE THE
SAME OUTLOOK THAT MITCH
McCONNELL DOES.
HE SAID THAT AFRICAN AMERICANS
VOTE IN THE SAME NUMBERS THAT
AMERICANS DO.
WAIT A MINUTE.
WHEN WE WERE PART OF A DIFFERENT
NATION?
WHEN WERE BLACK PEOPLE PART OF
AN OTHER CONGREGATION OF VOICES
WHO WERE OUTSIDE OF THE
PRECINCTS AND PROVIDENCE OF
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY?
WE KNOW THAT THERE'S A SENSE OF
BLACK PEOPLE AS THE OTHER AND
THESE STRATEGIES DEPLOYED BY
REPUBLICANS REVEAL THEIR
BELIEFS, ESSENTIALLY, ABOUT
BLACK CITIZENSHIP NOT BEING
LEGITIMATE.
>> MITCH McCONNELL MADE THAT
COMMENT WEDNESDAY, HE CAME OUT
FRIDAY, TWO DAYS LATER, TO
DIRECTLY ADDRESS THE MISTAKE,
SAYING IT WAS INNED A VERVE
TENT,